it was it was an incredible look that
was a great experience actually I I sort
of wandered into this into this business
inadvertently I was in the book
publishing business and I started to
publish books about technology and about
the internet so that I was I suppose
earlier than most through this product
that really had nothing to do with the
internet or technology nevertheless
being about those subjects introduced me
to this to this business and in New York
I became sort of very early one of the
few people who had any claim on knowing
anything about this business although
I'd like to footnote that I really knew
nothing at all and but as this business
started to to heat up anybody who had
any claim on it was suddenly at the at
center stage and it was opportunity
knocking venture capital came my way and
I began to build a company again having
no idea what kind of company I was
building or really any idea about the
business in which I was building this
this this company so this was truly
learning on the job
and I can only say in my defense that
virtually everybody who was starting
intranet businesses at that point in
time was also learning on the job
and I and I learned not enough but
nobody in those days learned enough and
everyone virtually everyone went under
and I went under as well I was in the
fortunate position to be able to to tell
the story and I wrote a book called burn
rate and
and that wish I still think is serves us
one of the great cautionary tales of of
the period but I would do it again in a
heartbeat
I took certain steps when I when I
started Newser to ensure that that that
that I had gotten somewhat older and I
didn't think that I would necessarily be
able to my my system would be able to to
tolerate the highs and lows of of the
first experience in in the internet so I
went into Newser with with a few safety
measures my partner in Newser is someone
who absolutely knows what he's doing who
has started two successful companies on
the Internet he founded Hoover's comm
and took that public and then sold his
dun & bradstreet
and he started high being which another
news database company which he sold so I
feel in remarkably good hands the the
editor-in-chief of news there is also
Caroline Miller who was the editor in
chief of New York magazine incredibly
professional and and tenacious and
accomplished woman so in reality at
Newser I do very little